what's going on guys this is Rob and
everything over the course of this video
is going to be ridiculously important
even though it seems like it might not
be right so what this does picking up
off the last video that we did what this
does is this initially opens with
basically the molloids showing up to the
surface world now for those of you guys
who don't know malloy's are basically
Subterranean dwellers and depending on
what story you're reading they serve
different purposes here in the main
Marvel Universe they're ruled by mole
man he's kind of like their their
overarching guy he's not overly
important he's actually the first
villain the Fantastic Four fought in the
history of Marvel Comics but it's one of
these things where when he arrives here
on the scene it's not to spark a fight
with a fantastic four instead it's here
to actually ask them for help and the
reason why is because somewhere along
the line over the course of his history
the high evolutionary had created a city
for himself now we're gonna see him in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe right he's
coming up but the thing behind this is
that Herbert Windham is a guy who is
obsessed with jump starting the
evolution of various things but
somewhere along the line prior to this
he had built a city below New York and
the intention was to basically
demonstrate to kind of the scientific
community that he was able to manipulate
The evolutionary structure of various
beings and then when the city was ready
when the Ascension engine was prepared
that the city would basically rise up
and by virtue of the Ascension engine
would basically kind of activate or jump
start The evolutionary state of beings
across the world in essence it would
push Humanity to its next evolutionary
State the thing behind this is that
ultimately it was abandoned that what
had happened is when the Ascension
engine was activated it didn't evolve
anything it actually devolved beings
right it sent them back to an earlier
state in their evolution and so the
result of this is that ultimately uh
Herbert Windham the high evolutionary
was kind of forced out of his own City
he essentially took off right they
literally ran him out of town and the
result is that he ended up taking up
residence in Wonder Gore Mountain and
has basically been there ever since the
concern that moleman has is because of
the intelligence of Reed Richards he's
seemingly the only one that can stop the
city from surfacing and prevent the
Ascension engine from activating and
basically kind of devolving the entirety
of humanity and so what ends up
happening is a Fantastic Four basically
transitioned to the Subterranean realm
with moleman now some of the things here
are kind of interesting and kind of cool
right geodes and stuff like that it's
one of the things to know about the
molloids they exist all over the world
but there is a specific tribe that
basically holds its allegiance to mole
man right so it's kind of a series of
fractured kingdoms if you want to call
it that it's kind of a primitive
depiction of how they operate but there
are all these different things that have
been built now the funny thing about
this is that Jonathan Hickman actually
went into detail on some of this stuff
in his shield miniseries which actually
took him years to finish but he wanted
to detail with that stuff which we can
cover if you guys are interested but
once they actually get to the city of
the high evolutionary one of the things
that they realize is that first and
foremost when it comes to the malloys
and in terms of them being affected by
the city that while it devolved them
physically it evolved them mentally and
so basically they're smarter than they
used to be but when they devolved they
actually devolved more to a humanoid
state which is kind of interesting
because you would expect it to be the
inverse right they would evolve to look
more like humans as opposed to the other
way around but once they're in there and
they start to realize there's not much
they can do to actually stop the city
from moving to the surface although they
can find a way to deactivate the
Ascension engine now what ends up
happening is Ben Grimm basically leaps
out of the ship and heads into the city
itself now a lot of this is kind of an
ongoing theme and it's not something
that Hickman directly hits on it's more
inferring based on Ben Grimm's history
but one of the things to know is that
ever since Ben Grimm became the thing
he's always kind of been looking for a
way to get back to his human form and
the logic that Ben Grimm has even if he
doesn't necessarily speak it openly is
that if the Ascension engine physically
devolved the molloids to where they
looked more humanoid in nature but it
basically evolved their intelligence it
could do the same thing to Ben Grimm it
could send him back into his human form
but also make him smarter and that's
literally really what he's shooting for
here now as he's in there he is exposed
to the radiation of the Ascension engine
and it's why the Fantastic Four
themselves don't immediately jump out
because they need some kind of
protection from that so that's why you
see Ben Grimm's physical appearance
change like his brain or his head gets
bigger but the important thing here is
he is able to rescue a couple of the
Malloy children who haven't evolved yet
they still maintain their previous form
but of course Ben Graham ends up getting
back onto the vessel and then they
basically leave and because there's no
way to stop the rising of the city the
city does come to the surface so the
thing about this is we transition to a
presentation that's kind of given to the
Fantastic Four by Susan storm and what
we end up learning is that at some
previous point in time there ended up
being something that was discovered
called vostok station and that initially
belonged to the Russians but that
basically it's being used as kind of a
research post that there are scientists
at the moment who are studying it based
on a grant that was given by The
Fantastic Four Foundation now there is
something called the Future Foundation
that's something that we'll explore
probably here in the next couple weeks
that's when that'll become relevant
because the Future Foundation is just
really really cool but the thing about
this is that Susan storm actually
realizes that there at least kind of
tells a Fantastic Four that no one
specifically knows what's down there but
whatever it is that's down there is of
course worth exploring and worth looking
into but where the Fantastic Four are
funding this based on their kind of
scientific curiosity Advanced idea
mechanics is likely looking to try to
weaponize it and what Advanced idea
mechanics has been doing is about five
miles away from where the Fantastic Four
station is set up the advanced idea
mechanics is basically slant drilling so
drilling at an angle to try to reach
whatever's below vostok station before
uh the Fantastic Four can get there and
so ultimately the Fantastic Four just
kind of like let's go exploring so they
end up basically kind of diving down
there and checking it out of course
they're kind of given a few warnings
here and there based on the staff and
it's kind of like look you know there's
a few things you need to be concerned of
and so on but the reality here is the
Fantastic Four is a team that's explored
the Multiverse so checking out just kind
of a giant sort of heat structure kind
of in the in the Antarctic which
seemingly isn't supposed to be there uh
it's not a big deal right it's not a
huge issue for them and so once they get
down there they actually end up arriving
at the same time as advanced idea
mechanics and that's when a kind of
fight breaks out not really between the
Fantastic Four and aim but the actual
occupants of what's below vostok station
and that's when you end up having this
kind of truce that's form because where
Advanced idea mechanics is nefarious
here the Fantastic Four join these
forces to basically defeat aim and when
that happens the aimed guys are just
kind of they're taken out of the picture
and the Fantastic Four are brought to
this Race's leader essentially and
that's when things get interesting now
something to know here is in order to
understand what we're getting ready to
talk about next you kind of have to
understand the nature of the history of
Marvel Comics so I'll make sense of it
as we go through the in-universe history
of Earth and all that kind of stuff
because the reality here is that the
individuals that house this area that
were Bostock station is based these are
basically atlanteans but they're not
atlanteans as you know them they're not
ruled by Namor the Submariner now the
Fantastic Four are basically given these
kind of telepathic objects that allow
them to communicate with this race
because they don't speak the same
language and the truth is just try to
learn how to speak their language would
take too long if the human race was even
capable of doing it at all but the funny
thing here is that when the Fantastic
Four get to these guys they say like
we're atlanteans and this is Atlantis
and their response is no that doesn't
make any sense Atlantis is destroyed now
this is where we start getting into the
history of things for those of you guys
who are familiar with Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers you know that
Atlantis as we for the most part know it
and really the atlanteans themselves
were almost completely and totally
annihilated by the wakandans in response
to name of the Submariner during the
events of Avengers vs X-Men attacking
wakanda and killing countless wakandans
what Reid Richards is talking about here
is a story that took place in Marvel in
the mid-1990s which was called called
Atlantis rising and it was literally
where Atlantis was brought to the
surface by Morgan lafaye which resulted
in the deaths of a multitude of
atlanteans itself but the bigger picture
here and the reason why these guys are
even here in the first place and is
something that's not readily explained
here by Jonathan Hickman is that when it
comes to the atlanteans their roots go
all the way back to the celestials so
the way this worked is that at a
previous point in time Atlantis was a
trading hub for the world right
literally Atlantis was an island that
could be accessed by the surface and a
lot of people just went there right
people from all over the world would
meet in Atlantis they would trade goods
Services different things like that when
the celestials showed up a second time
during the second host to basically
examine their experiment of creating the
deviants and the eternals that the
deviants attacked the celestials and in
doing so the celestials initiated the
great cataclysm which sunk the city of
Atlantis what ended up happening here is
that those individuals who survived most
of them ended up taking residence in the
city of Atlantis itself in the Island of
Atlantis even though it had been sunk
and there were Magics that were used
that allowed them to breed underwater
there was some genetic modification and
so on and so forth and that's how you
basically end up with the atlanteans as
you know them people with blue skin who
live underwater what also happened here
is there were some individuals who took
off to other parts of the world and that
basically led to their own individual
Atlantean kingdoms being formed but they
operated in secret nobody ever knew they
were there because vostok station right
this entire Citadel basically where
these atlanteans reside is essentially
cut off from the rest of the world this
is something that will be explored later
on down the line because Namor will
learn of their existence and the real
question you have to ask is when Namor
learns that these other atlanteans exist
out there what happens but the kicker
here and the reason why this little bit
of a story matters is because it does
build into that we do need this so we
can understand that but what also
happens is that when it comes to this
Atlantean group they have individual
kingdoms but they only ever speak as a
singular person meaning one individual
represents them right so it's like the
ambassador of the United it's going to
other parts of the world and that's why
when you have read and you have Susan
and you have Ben Grimm and you have
Johnny and they like fought against
Advanced idea mechanics these atlanteans
don't understand that to them it's
strange because they're like we have
different kingdoms sure but we are a
unified Collective and in times when the
kingdom needs to be spoken for only one
of us speaks for them and the response
of Reed is that's not how we do things
right each individual person has a
collective voice the point of this is
that Susan storm is kind of appointed or
really allowed to step into the role of
what's basically the speaker for
Humanity now she does this for a couple
different reasons the first of these is
that Susan storm is level-headed the
other reason why Susan storm is taking
this role is because she knows a time
will come when Neymar the Submariner
will become aware of them and Namor has
always been trying to bang Susan storm
and depending on who you talk to man
they kind of have a couple of times it's
never overly stated by Marvel not that
I'm aware of but it's one of those
things where like you know they may have
touch naughty bits but that's the reason
why she undertakes this role But
continuing on right because again this
video is really more of kind of like hey
this is setting the stage for stuff we
end up switching over to the Inhumans
right now normally we don't care about
the Inhumans the Inhumans suck they
never really serve a useful purpose this
is gonna be cool and in fact it's one of
like three times in the history of
Marvel Comics when the Inhumans are ever
cruel at all but what we end up doing is
basically switching over to the Inhumans
as they take off to leave Earth to
confront the cree now this was Jonathan
Hickman writing this story during the
time when Dan Abner and Marvel Comics is
taking care of all the space-faring
stuff right the reason why that matters
is because during this point in time
blackbolt of the Inhumans traveled to
the cree Homeworld of Hala and
challenged Ron and the accuser who was
the existing ruler of the cree race for
control of the cree he ends up winning
and then that leads into the war of
Kings when you have Vulcan the Omega
Level brother of Cyclops who faces off
against uh Black Bolt and then of course
it leads to like the cancer verse
storyline Thanos imperative all that
kind of stuff so it's one of those
really really cool tidbits here but the
reality is that in response to
blackpool's absence what you do have is
a guy who's kind of a kind of a steward
of the inhuman City or the inhuman
government if you want to call it that
but when the Fantastic Four get there
they're ultimately met by this guy who's
referred to as Dal democ now this guy is
going to be very important later on down
the line but he simply refers to this
giant ship that is essentially touched
down on the blue area of the Moon as the
Universal City now the blue area of the
moon was originally created by the cree
it was basically a section of the Moon
that was given oxygen so the cree could
operate there and that's really what's
explained here that we kind of get this
explanation regarding the history of the
Inhumans in Marvel Comics where Reed
Richards is aware of the fact that they
were created by the cree but he doesn't
know how far reaching it is and what
we're told here is that the cree Supreme
intelligence's public explanation to
everybody out there regarding the
creation of the Inhumans is to basically
kind of weaponize them to a degree right
that if the cree race wants to be able
to subdue and subvert other Empires
Across the Universe the best way to do
that that is to genetically modify
members of that race so that at some
future point in time they can undergo
exposure to Terra Genesis and they will
in turn be activated they'll realize
that their cree insurgents and they
could in turn just kind of operate
within those kingdoms and bring it down
from the inside so think of it as like
the cree equivalent of Marvel's secret
Invasion Scrolls secretly infiltrating
Earth with the intention of destroying
everybody there and then taking the
planet for themselves that's really what
it was and it's a really cool concept
the thing about this is that what we're
told is that as far as the people on
Earth are concerned the Fantastic Four
and those guys the Inhumans on Earth are
the only Inhumans but the the Supreme
intelligence had done this Across the
Universe so you have all these different
inhuman groups that have been created
now here's something that's explained
later on but we're going to go ahead and
cover it here that there came a prophecy
that the Supreme intelligence became
aware of which basically meant the
inhuman project would lead to the
destruction of the Crete this prophecy
came to fruition when Black Bolt travels
to Cree space challenges one of the
accuser and then takes over the cree
Kingdom the reason why this matters is
because in response to that prophecy the
Supreme intelligence ordered the
destruction of the inhuman project so
basically all in humans Across the
Universe were annihilated except for the
four inhuman tribes that we're going to
be seeing here and so it's cool because
when this Revelation is given to read
what he's told is that because they are
what's left of the Inhumans across the
universe that instead of kind of
operating as individual tribes they had
unified they had basically come together
and so what you have are called the
universal Inhumans and they exist in
four different groups the first one are
the centaurian family right so like the
royal family which is led by their
matriarch Ula undanta who you guys
remember the centaurians basically from
like Guardians of the Galaxy the movie
but then you also have the ruling moored
Council which is presided over by the
badoon queen and has a name that I can't
pronounce but following this you also
have the chameleons Now The Chameleons
are not new to the Fantastic Four and in
fact the white main fan family which was
a which is a member of the chameleon
race actually has had dealings with a
Fantastic Four and they've been a part
of power pack which is really really
cool but they're not unfamiliar with
them but following that you also have
the goddess Avo who basically rules the
dire race now the dire race are really
really cool they're very very powerful
but they're also very dangerous but the
thing about this and what's really
established here is that regardless of
what a legion says their races may have
had in the past regardless of what role
they play the reality here is they're
unified under the basis of inhumanity
now one thing that I want to explain
here none of these groups have seemingly
undergone their racist version of Terra
Genesis they still look like the races
they're supposed to look like once they
undergo whatever their Terror Genesis
process is then they'll look totally
different the reality here and really
what Dahl domack basically says is that
for them when Black Bolt returns because
Black Bolt is kind of the inhuman right
like the guy who was prophesied to lead
the the universal Inhumans themselves to
kind of form a House of six that what's
going to take place here is that he's
going to be the one to lead them right
and they're going to essentially find a
new home for themselves now of course
the question of the Fantastic Four is
when this time comes what's this new
home going to be and they're like Earth
we're gonna invade your world
the thing about this though is that it's
still an opportunity for diplomacy but
one thing to also remember here and the
reason why Reed Richards doesn't really
order the Fantastic Four to immediately
attack is lest we forget Reed Richards
and Black Bolt are both members of the
Illuminati so this is one of those
things that can kind of be solved behind
closed doors so there's no need for war
yet because diplomacy is still an
opportunity it's still something that
can be done but following this we end up
switching over to Johnny's storm what
this does is it introduces something
called The Cult of the negative zone now
they will become incredibly important
later on down the line but for Johnny's
storm all that really happens is he ends
up like meeting this girl at the club
who's like super hot and so he ends up
taking her back to the Baxter building
because as anybody who reads A Fantastic
Four knows it's kind of Johnny Storm's
thing where he's like I'm a member of
the Fantastic Four and like they're all
like he's already got him hooked based
on that and he's like let me show you
the Baxter building which gets them even
more hooked and then he's like let me
show you the view and before you know it
they're touching naughty bits and so the
thing behind this is that once this girl
gets up there from John his perspective
is business as usual but the thing about
this is that this girl is not all she
seems to be because the reality is the
cult of the Negative Zone operates out
of a nightclub called the other side of
zero and what they're doing is they're
positioning themselves in such a way to
where they can access the Negative Zone
but the truth about this is that this
girl is basically a host for a member of
the annihilation wave which is referred
to as an intrusion but the importance
behind this is that the Negative Zone
houses basically a whole universe like
just it's massive in scale right so in
the Multiverse and Marvel Comics you've
got an infinite number of universes some
of which are similar and some of which
are drastically different in the
entirety of the Multiverse you only have
one Negative Zone and that houses being
is like a nihilus who basically invaded
the main Marvel Universe during the
annihilation storyline just different
things like that right but it's like a
huge place this just got all kinds of
Life teaming in it the reality is that
with this girl being a host for one of
the anthrosians for a member of the
annihilation wave that what happens is
it basically kind of I'm merges from her
back in a pretty gruesome way right it's
pretty Twisted but basically has a bomb
strapped on it now this girl under the
influence of the uh of the the
anthrosion had opened the portal to the
negative Zone it wasn't for the purpose
of like allowing the entire Annihilation
way through right like that army of
billions of bugs basically that's not
really what it was for instead it was to
gain access to the negative Zone and
when Johnny's storm follows it through
right he basically tells Herbie the
robot like keep the portal open for five
minutes I'll be back if five minutes
passes and I haven't returned close the
portal and I'll find some other way to
get back in here but the reality is that
once he gets to the other side once
again what he ends up realizing is the
entirety of the Negative Zone isn't a
state of kind of Civil War where you've
basically got the forces of blastar
who's one of the individuals that exists
in the negative Zone leading his whole
Army who's gone to war with annihilus
and what's going on here is that these
two guys Waging War against each other
is leading to like world after World
kind of falling and being assaulted and
so on and so forth so think of it like a
universe-wide war where you basically
have the forces of annihilus against
everyone else when Johnny Storm gets in
there what he realizes is that in Trojan
had actually brought a bomb with it and
the entire purpose was for the cult of
the Negative Zone to allow one of those
enthrosions to enter into the positive
matter Universe into the main Marvel
Universe grab a bomb and then get back
to the negative Zone again but because
the Fantastic Four the Baxter building
is the only real way in and out of the
Negative Zone unless somebody else
somewhere happens to open a portal it's
the safest Surefire way to get back and
forth from that location so that's why
it ended up posing as that girl to get
access to the the portal to the negative
Zone in the first place once it gets in
there it detonates the bomb and it
basically kills the leadership on that
world and Johnny Storm has no choice but
to flee back to the positive matter
Universe now the reason why that matters
and one of the cool things that you
learn from this is that within the
Negative Zone one of the things that had
happened is they had basically
repurposed prison 42 which was a prison
that was created by Reed Richards during
Civil War which is where they housed
those individuals who refused to
register ultimately prison for 42 was
abandoned right nobody really uses it
anymore but it's been repurposed by the
forces of the Negative Zone and turned
into a giant expansive City but once uh
once Johnny gets back to the positive
matter Universe he ends up meeting with
Reed Richards now this sets the stage
for Johnny's moment so this is
ridiculously important and we're gonna
reflect back on this but there comes a
point when Reed sits down with Johnny
and it's like hey man we need to talk
and Johnny's like okay what's going on
and and Regis kind of looks at him it's
like what's the deal here and that's
when Johnny's like yeah I don't know
what I was thinking man like honestly
leaving a Negative Zone portal open like
that the entire Annihilation wave could
have just entered in you might we could
have been facing Annihilation all over
again the annihilation event and they
would have invaded Earth I could have
gotten everybody killed right he could
have gotten like Franklin killed he
could have gotten Valeria killed he
could have gotten everybody killed where
Earth itself could have been completely
and totally overtaken because Johnny was
being Reckless and Johnny wasn't
thinking and that's Reid's response here
is look man here's the deal right like
things are changing the world's changing
and the reality here is we all have
something going on Susan storm is now an
emissary for a newly discovered race of
atlanteans that exists out there and
there's going to be some kind of a
conflict that's likely going to unfold
with name of the Submariner so we have
to be prepared for that I've got stuff
going on that I can't even tell you
about which of course he's referring to
the Council of reads and so it's like
everybody has stuff going on man so
here's the question you have to ask
yourself Johnny like what do you stand
for right we all stand for something and
so it was the last little tidbit here
and this group's going to become
important what is going on is back at
the universal inhuman City that as a
kind of show of their power kind of a
display of their power it's sort of a
blood sacrifice for an offering if you
want to give it that that what ends up
happening is the universal and humans
end up creating a group called The Light
Brigade which is basically a coming
together of their most capable Warriors
which is designed to basically show the
Inhumans once blackbolt arrives we're
worth your time and effort right we're
worth your attention we can bring
something to the table and to kind of
demonstrate the power of the Light
Brigade what they end up doing is
sending them into the Negative Zone the
idea here being if they can face off
against the 4 forces of annihilists and
if they can be successful and come back
alive then it will prove their metal
right so it's kind of like a Warriors
tribute it's a way to demonstrate their
capabilities right like this this that
kind of a thing right Building Up
character and whatnot but they will
become important later I promise you
they will but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace